Bruce Lee is one of the most respected
icons among martial artists strength
athletes and beyond during his lifetime
Bruce Lee's unparalleled commitment to
his training made him a true specimen of
an athlete and a fighter thus over the
course of many articles and videos on
this site I have explored the methods he
used to train those have been some of
the most popular videos on this channel
by far and so in celebration of this 100
thousand subscriber milestone I thought
it made sense to return to this subject
once again in this video I want to do
something a little different and tie
everything we've looked at in the past
into a single modern and accomplishable
routine that anyone can follow Bruce was
extremely ahead of his time but with
today's knowledge how might you train
differently and next week in order to
cover the martial arts training aspect
of this program I'm gonna be handing you
able to someone who's far more of an
expert on that topic than me the
excellent grant stevens bruce lee did a
lot of heavy bag work and during this he
would divide his training based on types
of strikes pretty much like a
bodybuilding split yeah David practices
kicks and days when he who practices
punches Bruce Lee followed a
weightlifting program that consisted
primarily of compound lifts these were
relatively light and targeted the entire
body for each workout I've covered these
in full in previous videos the weights
used weren't extremely heavy and he also
added in some accessory movements like
curls and good mornings he's also
reported to have experimented with a
range of alternative training methods a
certain points during his career Bruce
Lee was named to run every single day
other times he's reported to have run
four miles three times a week this was
performed in a fartlek manner meaning
that he would alternate between
different speeds
finally Bruce Lee trained flexibility
and you can see his impressive free
range of movement in a number of his
film simple though some of this might
look consider now how many aspects that
are to his training the other issue is
that we don't have a single resource
that tells us how to incorporate all
these different facets into a single
program and there are simply more
options today that I think Bruce Lee
would have considered for his own
training without dedicating your entire
life to training like he did you aren't
likely to get quite to Bruce's standards
we can certainly head in that direction
in a smart and methodical manner the
strength training I'm gonna schedule
three full body routines one of these
will consist of lifting somewhat heavy
using compound movements one will
involve training with calisthenics and
the last would be comprised of accessory
movements device develop a more
well-rounded physique we're gonna try
and tie all of this into one seamless
program begin with we have our first
full body day consisting of compound
lifts and movements so what's going on
here well to start with we have our
overcoming isometric moves that means
setting up a weight so it won't move and
then attempting to pull push or squat
it's using maximum force and exploding
into it this trains the muscle fiber
recruitment and is one of the best
tricks used by old-time strongmen and
Bruce Lee himself as far as your body is
concerned you're trying to lift more
than your 1 rep max and this forces
strength developing adaptations use
three joint angles for each movement and
holds each repetition for six seconds
you'll only need a 20 second rest
between each set and for more on why
should set it up like this check out my
dedicated videos on isometrics then we
move more into the bulk of the workout
which is using a number of compound
lifts at 70% one rep max this is truer
to Bruce Lee's original training than if
we were to use the deadlift squat and
bench press and higher weights using
this slightly lighter weight allows us
to train for explosiveness
rather than max strength and size when
training these movements demas to
accelerate as much as possible during
the concentric phase this is the
compensatory acceleration or dynamic
effort methods that we discussed in the
previous video on strength training
there's also the perfect analogue for
Bruce's own speed lifting technique in
short when you try and move as quickly
as possible through these movements you
train your explosiveness and starting
strength from your adaptations and type
to be muscle fiber development you
practice generating force quickly which
alters your rate coding the result has
obvious benefits for martial artists not
only can you punch faster and harder
when grappling I'll be the athlete
capable of generating the most power the
most quickly you can throw the opponent
off balance Bruce Lee was known to use
speed training where he'd try and
complete workouts as quickly as possible
and this is likely why remember he was
all about those moments of truly
explosive power of having that strength
accessible at all times and you have to
train you have to keep your reflexes so
that when you want it it's there and
that's what we're looking to Train here
we're ending with kettlebell swings
which nicely develop the posture
a chain further great after those squats
and offer an awesome form of resistance
cardio HIIT so the calisthenics day
looks like this absolutely think if
Bruce Lee was around today he would have
been hopping on the gymnastic strength
training bandwagon heck he probably
would have been the one to get it
trending this type of strength covers
everything that Bruce was interested in
building true cost ability mobility and
functional power I also believe that
calisthenics in general offers one of
the best options for someone who wants a
physique like Bruce Lee's without
necessarily training exactly like him
working with your own bodyweight will
help to develop lean hard muscle while
at the same time giving you the kind of
relative strength the Bruce excelled at
and the same kind of body control when
you performed planche for instance
you're trying to keep your entire body
rigid and to develop the kind of
invincible core they weren't sure you
can take blow to the stomach deliver
more powerful blows and never get
knocked over so for the first portion of
this workout you'll be practicing
holding planche and front lever
progressions for up to a minute twice
for each movement so if you can't do
planche for a minute yet then you'll
start with the crow pose and hold that
for as much of a minute as possible if
you have to take a rest that's fine then
jump back into it until the minute is
over once it can hold each one for a
minute all the way through you can
increase the difficulty by using tuck
planche or full planche for example just
working through those progression the
next portion will be a rather explosive
full body routine with lots of
plyometrics once you can perform each
movement for the full number of reps add
some extra weight with a weighted vest
as part of this workout as a small
circuit completed for speed consisting
of pull-ups press ups and jump squats
this will make you explosive fast and
endurance develop that kind of power for
long periods of time it's also fantastic
metabolic conditioning finally there
accessory day looks like this the cable
punches and single arm overhead press
will help develop that core strength the
obliques and talk training in the
transverse plane like this as an
overlooked aspect of strength training
in many programs this is also perfect
for adding power to punches and with
targeting things like wrist strength
finger strength and nothing conditioning
as well all things that Bruce Lee was
known to have done and which will make
you a better fighter at the same time
this workout is devised to include all
of those smaller muscle groups that
might otherwise have been able look
we've got the spider-man crews to
develop our contralateral strength and
our body awareness and the pike pulses
and downward dog push-ups will really
help to develop further mobility on top
of any extra mobility you're doing final
cardiac finished it here is using battle
ropes which I think Druce would probably
have liked a lot either ideal resistance
cardio lets me burn fat and prove
endurance all without cannibalizing
muscle and now on to carve you said
Bruce's experimentations with concepts
like fartlek paint him as clearly ahead
of his time this is a form of
high-intensity interval training that
would allow him to increase his aerobic
capacity mitochondrial density vo2 max
fat burning all in less time than
typical steady-state cardio there
follows that we're going to include
something similar in our own regime
which will fuel short bursts of
high-intensity anaerobic activity so
obviously that's why I've built in the
finishers into the program such as the
kettlebell swings and the battle rope
course when doing HIIT you're basically
going all-out for a little while and
then resting for a little while and
member zooming you can start by going
all-out for 30 seconds and resting for a
minute and then as you improve you're
gonna switch that over so that you're
going all-out for a minute and resting
for 30 seconds for example loosely would
also experiment with running with
resistance pushing his anaerobic
threshold with tempo runs I recommend
that you attempt a threshold runner
tempo run once every two to four months
so a threshold thrown is a run that you
perform most attempting to cover the
most distance possible in a given amount
of time normally about thirty minutes
this isn't sprinting but it isn't
jogging it's just going all-out as best
you can with an eye to continuous
exertion for thirty minutes
what's also notable is that Bruce Lee
practiced large amounts of low intensity
steady-state cardio that is to say that
he would go for long jogs at roughly 70%
of his max heartrate this is important
for any fighter intending on going more
than one round or to paraphrase Bruce
himself if you don't have a good
cardiovascular system you need to look
into a more peaceful hobby
indeed adaptations occur at this
intensity that you can't accomplish with
HIIT training alone for example
steady-state cardio will increase the
size of the left ventricle of the heart
including stroke volume and lowering
resting heart rate that's why we're
going to include 1 to 2 steady-state
cardio runs per week depending on what
you can manage to fit in
thanks a ton for watching guys I hope
you found this video useful and
interesting if you did then please leave
a like share around that helps me out
immensely if you enjoy programs like
this functional training then check out
the link in the description down below
and you can find my ebook and training
program super functional training in the
description you'll also find a link to
the website where you'll find the full
article the go-to of this video
including the full programs stay tuned
for next week of course for part 2 with
Grant hit subscribe if you want to see
more like this thanks a ton for watching
this one and I'll see you next time bye
for now